so here I am mopping the floor while
enjoying my Persian but it's not always
fun I made a video where I talked about
my difficulties with Korean and I'm also
struggling with Arabic and sometimes
learning a language can be like those
two characters in Greek mythology there
were Sisyphus who was trying to push a
rock up a hill and however much he
pushed it up it rolled back down again
or Tantalus who was in a cave and he
reached out for this fruit tree and it
was always just out of his reach and he
was standing in water and what he wanted
to drink no matter how low he bent the
water would recede so it was always just
out of his grasp language learning can
be that way but I don't care because I
know that my Korean and my Arabic are
always going to be there I look forward
to going back to them it'll be fun but
now I have to get back to my inning the
floor